robbie what are you singing first later
i want to be like you
oh
i i know that's duet so you're not
seeing it alone are you no i i'm not i'm
with somebody i love very much
hey can you sing by the way can you sing
no no i can't at all
no but that's never stopped me
ollie mr ollymers ladies
the song is from uh the new album which
is swings both ways
he's such a good title he's a really
good title he's offering you how much
swings
it's in shops and on computers and
things now and uh the songs you wrote a
lot of these songs uh kind of around the
time that i was pregnant after teddy was
born yeah do you have more of a sense of
your legacy what what your daughter's
got to think of daddy well i'm quite an
unconscious person person
what she doesn't know about me is that
i'm an unconscious persian
she must find this out about it one day
but i you know i uh this is daddy this
is what daddy's going to do daddy's
always going to be that you know say say
first and think second so
sorry teddy um but yeah we were writing
we were writing about the time she was
born
and i always
see songs as you know certain songs that
i write as being um
uh
promises that i make i made one promise
to ida on an album called reality kill
the video star song of court i won't do
that to you and it's about not leaving
her and not breaking the heart and as
soon as i'd written it and sung it in
the booth that was sealed i meant it and
then i wrote go gentle for teddy and
that's for all your days and nights i'm
going to be there and that's kind of
like my seal and my promise and um
you know because i was always i've been
really selfish and been a pop star since
i was 16 i've had everything done for me
i i know relatively little and now i've
got to look after this little person so
i was terrified that i was not going to
be up to it
and dad's really connected with that
song go gentle oh i've been
more than any other song that i've ever
done i'm having people stop in the cars
roll down the window and say this
you know it feels like the song's
reached its destination because dads
look at me with that knowing look in
their eyes and i know they they've got
it was teddy born here
yes she was born here yeah we were
actually at the
the hello teddy moment were you there
for the birth yes i was was down the
business end
uh yeah i was well done it was like my
favorite pub burning down
left on that tire
did you read have you rebuilt her uh we
we haven't we haven't bothered
rebuilding it yet
uh because there might be another one on
the way
yeah you don't want to go about it twice
to live with the ruins for now
this feels like overhearing something a
doctor's surgery
we'll just live with that shall we we'll
just live with charles can i just have
which camera sorry ida
you have a beautiful food there
we we
did the radio last saturday and he was
going i say things i shouldn't on chat
shows and i was going no no you'll be
fine
i've turned up to places and the look on
people's faces they realize i'm not
robin williams
seriously
if you'd like to ease your pants down